one thing I've Learned about being in a relationship
is that you should never talk about your partner behind their back
or complain about them to other people
family members, co workers
whatever it may be
because A, that's none of their business
And B, it'll make your friends
family and co workers start to not like your partner
that's just how it is
they’re bias because they're your friend
they're your coworker
so they start looking at him as the evil person
or her, whoever it may be
if you have problems
save that for therapy
because complaining about your partner is never
ever going to help
I've been guilty of this okay
I was young once
I still am young
But sometimes it feels nice to get things off your chest
The best route is always going to therapy
getting things off your chest that way
not to your friends
family or co workers
Also nobody likes a complainer
so if you're always complaining about things and you're not changing them
or you're still staying in that relationship
then people are gonna start not liking you
that's just how it is
because it does affect them
even if you're complaining
seems innocent
it's not
So try not to complain about your partner
it's not helping anyone
and it's really not fair to your partner